let's bring in ray rata who covers the
Warriors NBC Sports Bay Area hi ray how
are you your business thank you Ray
I appreciate that starting off on the
road did that represent the mood of the
Golden State Warriors fans that response
I just got none of your business um no I
think they're absolutely baffled because
they have been led to believe and
properly so that the Warriors are
playing the basketball of the future
when in fact the thing that's bringing
them down rather than this player not
doing well or that player being injured
is that they are losing to the
basketball of a decade ago they got 72
shot attempts last night which is not
only the lowest of the season but their
fourth lowest in four years they're not
passing the ball very well or very often
and the reason is that Houston which is
a team that everybody likes to
characterize as a team doesn't play any
defense has basically been choking them
off from doing anything they want to do
they're not comfortable at all and I
think that's the takeaway here is it
Houston has basically gone away from the
thing that you think of Houston as being
and now they're like the Spurs of 2007
and I think that's why people are
confused about wait a minute we're the
vanguard of the future why are we losing
to the basketball of the past explain
Kevin Durant his performance so far in
this series because he can be baffling
he can be unbelievable and then he can
be invisible I think there is a part of
him and this is dime-store psychology so
I know you'll really appreciate it
when things get discombobulated
offensively as they have been for the
Warriors and much of the city series he
takes it upon himself to save what is
essentially an ensemble team from its
own best instincts and when he does that
the offense tends to stagnate and then
he becomes easier to defend yes he puts
up numbers
but they're not really efficient numbers
and they don't really make the team
better because they become more
concentric it's not that he's a greedy
player it's that he tries too much to
help and as a result an offense that is
built on ball movement and almost sort
of an egalitarian you of what offense
should be becomes very much isolation
ball and he's merely the most obvious
example of it what do you expect to
happen in this next game well first you
have to tell me if Chris Paul's playing
secondly you have to tell me if Houston
can even play with Chris Paul at 60%
rather than the 80% he's been at I think
that's the answer to Game six if he is
not effective I mean that's 40 minutes
from a seven-man team if he's not
effective who Warriors win Game six and
then I think Houston probably wins game
seven because the home team is running
rampant in this whole postseason who's
going to take the heat if Golden State
doesn't go to the NBA Finals everybody
the the presumption all year is that the
Golden State is a dynasty with
everything but this series of rings and
they've been the prohibitive favorite
all along I think there are a lot of
people in the country who still think
they are dramatically the better team
but they've run into a houston team that
gives them everything that can possibly
want and more and I think everybody's
going to get it I think Steve Kerr look
at it I think Kevin Durant will get it
I think Stefan curry will get it I think
draymond Green will get it I think it's
got to be across the board because when
a team that everyone figured would
cakewalk to a championship doesn't even
get to the final everybody gets their
share could it be a good thing for
Golden State I think in one way maybe
this teaches them how to play when
they're uncomfortable because that's the
one thing is never really had
to do during this run the only other
team that forced them to play a style
they didn't want to play for any
appreciable amount of time was Memphis
in 2015 and they ended up winning two of
the first three games before the
Warriors made an adjustment and you know
basically left Andre
Andrew Bogut to guard nobody and they
left Tony Allen unguarded and Memphis
couldn't forget what to do with that and
got run out in six but that is the only
time that they really were faced with a
style they couldn't cope very well and
2016 they lost twice big in Oklahoma
City but that was playing a style that
they're more comfortable with and they
were able to turn it around but this is
this is basically this is a tribute to
Mike D'Antoni and Jeff
zelich their defensive coach basically
figure out how to make the Warriors
uncomfortable and they haven't done well
with it how quickly do the Bay Area fans
move on to the 49ers if Golden State
drops out well in a nation full of front
runners they're always on the medal
stand I would imagine about two or three
days you know there'll be one day where
they go out to the parade that doesn't
happen and then they'll start getting
stuck into OTAs is there a chance though
ray we've overrated
greatly overrated Jimmy Garoppolo of
course there is okay we still are
dealing with in the small sample size
world yeah but what what do we know
about him as a quarterback well that he
took a really bad team and made the less
bad and a lot of people find him really
good-looking I don't know if that's the
standard but no it's it's myth making of
the first order that he now has to back
up yeah he looked real good in five
games and nobody was paying any
attention to but now comes the heavy
lifting and the heavy lifting is being
Jimmy Garoppolo when defensive
coordinators have had a full summer to
figure out what that means so yeah of
course we've overrated them but that's
what we do ray you're not overrated
well give it time I think you'll feel
differently by Monday I could but right
now you are not overrated you got up
early for us and I appreciate that right
well I was sort of hoping that Fritzi
would do about five minutes of his tight
twenty set I didn't have to cope with it
that would put you back to sleep ring
well put me to the bottle and eventually
you're right thank you Ray
it's a ray Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area
covers the Warriors it covers San
Francisco Sports for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]